a record 45
000 people crossed the channel on
dangerous small boats last year up from
just
284 years ago in that short time the
government has allowed criminal gangs to
take hold along the channel and along
our border at the same
Smugglers have halved home office Asylum
decisions have collapsed down 40 percent
the backlog and costly inappropriate
Hotel use has soared removals of
unsuccessful Asylum Seekers are down 80
percent on the last Labor government and
legal family reunion visas for refugees
are down 40 percent this is deeply
damaging chaos and there is no point in
ministers trying to blame anyone else
for it they have been in power for 13
years the Asylum system is broken and
they broke it
yeah yeah we need serious action to stop
dangerous Boat Crossings which are
putting lives at risk and undermining
border security and that
had plans for a cross-border border
lease unit for fast-track decisions and
returns to clear the backlog and end
Hotel use and a new agreement with
France and other countries but instead
today's statement is Groundhog Day the
Home Secretary has said anyone who
arrives illegally will be deemed
inadmissible and either returned to the
country they arrive from or a safe Third
Country
only that wasn't this Home Secretary it
was the last one
[Applause]
wasn't this bill it was the last one
passed only a year ago which did not
work and as part of last year's Bill the
home office considered 18
000 people as inadmissible for the
Asylum system because they had traveled
through safe third countries but because
they had no return agreements in place
just 21 of them were returned that is
not 0.1 the other 99.9 percent just
carried on often in hotels at an extra
cost of 500 million pounds and it didn't
deter anyone even more boats arrived so
what is different this time they still
don't have any return agreements in
place the Home Secretary herself has
admitted Rwanda is failing and even if
it gets going it will only take a few
hundred people so what will happen to
the other 99 of people under this bill
now she says she's going to detain the
well maybe for 28 days she could tell us
how many detention centers they will
need and how much that would cost but
even if she does what will happen when
people leave 28-day detention will she
make people desk attitude so they just
wandered the streets in total chaos
torture victims Afghan interpreters
families with children or will she put
them into indefinite taxpayer-funded
accommodation never returned anywhere
because they don't have the agreements
with Europe in place neither returned
nor given Sanctuary never having their
case resolved just forever in Asylum
accommodation and hotels she may not
call it the Asylum system but thousands
more people are still going to be in it
nevertheless
does it mean for the promises that we
made to the after Afghan interpreters
who served
but who were too late to make the last
flight out of Kabul as the Tyranny was
closing in on them the government told
them to flee and find another way here
and they told us to tell people that as
well but the resettlement scheme isn't
helping them and if they arrive in this
country finally this afternoon perhaps
by traveling through Ireland to get here
they will only ever be illegal in the
eyes of the government who relied on the
sacrifices they made for us
so if the government was serious it
would be working internationally to get
a proper new agreement in place with
France and Europe including return
agreements and properly controlled and
manage legal routes such as family
reunion and reform of resettlement
instead this bill makes this harder
unilaterally choosing to decide no
Asylum cases at all but expecting every
other country to carry on and they would
work with labor on our plan for a major
new cross-border police unit to go after
the criminal gangs but instead the
deputy chair of the conservative party
said yesterday we shouldn't go after the
gangs because well they've existed for
thousands of years that
and letting the gangs take hold on one
Smuggler told Sky News yesterday that
three-quarters of the Smugglers lived in
Britain yet barely any of them are being
prosecuted and they still haven't found
the hundreds of children missing from
Asylum hotels who've been picked up by
criminal gangs they could be setting out
a serious plan today and we would work
through them on it and so would everyone
across the country instead it's just
more chaos they say no ifs no buts but
all of us know they're going to spend
the whole of the next year iffing and
butting and looking for someone else to
blame
enough is enough we can't afford any
more of this slogans and not Solutions
just government by gimmick ramping up
the rhetoric on refugees but picking
fights simply to have someone else to
blame when things go wrong this bill
isn't a solution it is a con that risks
making the chaos worse Britain deserves
better than this chaos Britain is better
than this yeah foreign